bonjour jean de maillard merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france comment est-ce que vous
accueillez cette convocation on le
rappelle un trois syndicats de la
magistrature ainsi que l'association
anticor en déposer plainte
tout est comme je pense n'importe quel
citoyen je prends les trouve qu'on est
dans une situation un peu surréaliste
sur les quatre derniers garde des sceaux
deux sons vont être mises en examen et
un troisième a été condamné
je crois qu'il ya un problème en france
avec les garde des sceaux et les gars de
descente un problème avec la justice
et concrètement que risque eric dupond
moretti lui qui s'est déclaré je suis
extrêmement serein ça c'est beaucoup
trop tôt pour le dire
il va être mis très probablement
d'examen pour une prise illégale
d'intérêts ça concerne vous le savez des
faits qui lui sont reprochés
en tant que ministre de la justice ça
c'est une grande première parce que le
jusqu'à présent les garde des sceaux
n'ont jamais été mises en examen durant
leurs fonctions pour des faits commis en
tant que garde des sceaux monsieur noah
ça a été condamné mais après avoir été
garde des sceaux pas quand il était dans
l'entourage du garde des sceaux on
s'étonne de la rapidité des
investigations de la notification de la
convocation au ministre le jour même de
la perquisition la place vendôme
sk pas une coïncidence avec le
calendrier politique la présidentielle
dans dix mois maintenant est ce que
c'est une épine dans le pied des manuels
macron du nouveau monde une république
exemplaire même s'il ya quand même la
présomption d'innocence un faut dire
aussi un bon côté je crois qu'il faut en
finir avec cette idée que les juges sont
là pour faire de la politique
et pour régler les comptes avec les
hommes politiques
de services en examen en réalité elle
est attendue depuis presque un an
il ya la cour de cassation
plus exactement la commission des
requêtes de la cour de cassation a déjà
accepté l'ouverture d'une instruction en
disant que les faits étaient passibles
de poursuites
c'est donc une analyse qui avait été
fait je le rappelle par des magistrats
de la cour de cassation qui est la plus
haute juridiction judiciaire française
une perquisition a lieu après des mois
probablement d'en quête qui n'a pas été
particulièrement rapide
parce qu'en réalité dans cette affaire
les faits sont connus dès le départ et
il n'avait pas d'investigation
extraordinaire affaire donc
la perquisition et fait ça veut dire que
on va passer à une deuxième phase de
l'instruction qui effectivement la phase
des explications qui vont être demandés
à monsieur dupont moretti
selon vous est-ce qu'il doit
démissionner avec les panneaux routiers
bah écoutez c'est ça va on demande aux
magistrats d'être impartiaux non
seulement d'être impartiaux vient
d'avoir une apparence d'impartialité
ce qui va très loin parce que il suffit
qu'il y ait un soupçon de partialité
pour que les magistrats puissent se voit
reprocher une faute
on attend au moins du garde des sceaux
qui est quand même celui qui a entre les
mains
la carrière de la plupart des magistrats
d'être lui-même impartiale et d'inspirer
confiance
or justement ce qui lui est reproché
c'est de régler des comptes avec les
magistrats
au travers de décisions qu'il a prises
en tant que garde des sceaux pour des
faits qui le concernait quand il était
avocat
je crois que là il ya un mélange des
genres qui fait que
la république et quand même apparemment
à ses attentes pour ne pas dire plus
par une telle image tel peut donner à la
fois aux citoyens et aussi sur le plan
européen et international
le ministre de la justice a fait
allusion à une manoeuvre de l'union
syndicale des magistrats en vue
d'obtenir son édiction votre avis non il
ya il ya trois syndicats dans la
magistrature
le syndicat les deux syndicats
traditionnels
je sens le syndicat de la magistrature
et l'union syndicale des magistrats ont
déposé une plainte et le troisième
syndicat a suivi lui plus strictement la
procédure de la cour de justice en
saisissant le procureur général près
cette cour de justice de la république
mais les trois syndicats ont eu une
position semblable dans ce dossier et
qui exprime je crois
la position de la quasi-totalité des
magistrats qui ne comprennent pas que le
garde des sceaux puisse à être quelqu'un
qui règle ses comptes en tant qu ancien
avocat avec la magistrature
merci jean de maillard d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien magistrat vous êtes spécialiste
des affaires économiques et financières